hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments if you have a sibling you've
been blackmailed at least once I don't
know if my brother would agree to that
let me call him hey dude I I'm recording
a little video have you or ever
blackmailed me or have I ever
blackmailed you back mail yeah
blackmail yeah
cuz everyone keeps asking me later
saying that if I have a sibling that I
must have been blackmailed at least once
so if there's do you want to blackmail
me now well do you have anything that
you want to blackmail me with I don't
want to be left out of the loop you got
nothing yeah and everything I do
embarrassing is already on the internet
so no I've never been blackmailed run
into the pool and screamed my lovely
lady lumps okay alright off to my pool I
go my humps my humps my lovely lady
lumps sploosh lalala lalalala Oh No is
that a tsunami
oh yeah I'm gonna have a pool anymore so
that's the best I got can you play the
guitar for us please okay ah that's out
of tune also it's electric so it's
really [ __ ] not he rubble great stuff
I've been using I've been using rocks
myths to practice and that's fine and
all but it's really not the way I want
to play guitar so I'm gonna be getting
another acoustic pretty soon and I want
to be picking up a finger finger picking
style kind of like folksy whatever you
want to call it I don't know where I'm
gonna go with it but it's been falling
into music lately and it's been really
really nice it's it's super weird it's
ed Sheeran and Bruno Mars right now I
have no idea why but it's really I don't
know I'm getting into it I never really
pursued music before but now I'm just
starting to fall in love with it again
so where is subnautica you'll find
somewhere oh wait yeah it's right
[ __ ] man it's right there mark don't
look up turtle mouths Wow I gotta look
up turtle mouths why oh my god why why
[Applause]
have to do that to me mark how long did
it take you to get used to not feel
weird talking to a camera um it took a
while like it took a while if we look
back at one particular video of mine
it's one of my earliest vlogs and it was
so little bit awkward hello everybody my
name is markiplier and on today's show
we talk about 4000 subscribers the end
of the world
brand new reaction compilation 4000
subscribers that's incredible guys these
few times when I did a vlog I did him on
my t 3 i up against my white wall with
only daylight coming through the windows
I had no idea what I was doing and I had
no idea what I was talking about so I
kind of just went with it just be oh my
god this face here but I
went with it because it was something
that I felt like I needed to do as an
update I had to do this over again like
five times just because I didn't know
what I was gonna say so but but back
then you know it took a long time this
was somewhere in the range of two to
three months of me starting back in to
are starting to do YouTube videos so
when I came out of it
I really didn't know but I got more
comfortable as time goes on just because
a camera is very impersonal you're
talking to a machine so you know that
what you're saying isn't exactly
translating across so it's not like
there's another person there so trying
to treat a camera like another person is
really really hard skill but I'd say
about you know six months to a year
before I started to get comfortable and
then almost two years before I was fully
fully comfortable hey Mark can you
please please please get a musically if
you do my username is Sid Shaw I do have
a musically musically is [ __ ] lit
bruh right there I've got my musically
I've got videos up there right now that
you want to see you want a taste of the
good stuff if you want to find me on
musically go look up at nod markiplier
on musically that is my profile so go
get it and go watch it and follow me
there because you can expect all sorts
of musically goodness from me to you it
would be a shame if you suddenly tripped
okay my lumps my lumps my lovely oh no
trip spin spin
[Music]
oops will you be doing another Mario
Kart 8 deluxe video with Ethan I loved
seeing you guys crash into everything
and making goo jokes well you can look
out for more goo jokes coming your way
with me and Ethan coming at you with
some Mario Kart 8 action I do want to do
another one again that was a lot of fun
so expect more of that but hopefully we
will have matured enough not to make new
jokes by the time we get back now Who am
I kidding I'm just gonna make goo jokes
till the day I die if you could be a
rapper what would your name be by the
way love your vids they're like a rapper
name generator' Oh my name is marek my
last initial is F use nickname alright
here we go
boink Marky M fatal aka manic dog cut
damn that's a good rap name how about
another one Plast blaster MF nugget
spoon EMF cookie yes please just take
the MF out of there I'm Spoony cookie
that's my rap name
I'm Spoony cookie all day Pusha MF cool
k MC guns dr. M Markie M char face aka
lucid flash okay well any one of those
are good but you know my favorite Oh
coconuts keep [ __ ] the grass
[Music]
mark how deep can you make your voice go
not really like much voice down there so
hey taking pick whatever voice actually
was there hey mark are you gonna bring
unnecessary censorship back to be
perfectly honest I forgot that series
entirely existed completely and
absolutely forgot that unnecessary
censorship was even a thing on my
channel I'm gonna bring that back it's a
weird question but did you outgrow your
lucky flannel shirt like physically like
you can't wear it or do you think you
left it in another era of markiplier and
it's better off there no the truth is
actually much sadder the truth is it was
stolen and and and that wouldn't be such
a big deal like it was stolen that's
fine like III took it off when I was at
a convention at some point and then I
set it down and then it was gone if
someone has it out there but the worst
thing is that specific shirt he's not
sold anymore it was originally a target
not even a flannel it was actually not
flannel it was a very specific material
was a lightweight plaid it was so
comfortable it was perfect and it's not
on sale anymore the company that made it
I believe it was Massimo the company
doesn't make that version of that shirt
anymore so what it is is a classic and
unfortunately I just don't have it
anymore I've tried to get other flannels
but they're not the same it's just not
the same hey mark first thank you for
the amazing videos I love watching them
now you said many times that you like to
innovate and try new things on YouTube
but is there anything you would never do
in a video I don't know I'd like to
think I'm pretty open-minded about
things it's mostly things that I
couldn't do because I would love to try
anything like I'm not afraid to get
embarrassed and try new things
especially if they don't work for me but
when it comes to things I won't do I
won't do videos that hurt other people I
won't do videos that intentionally
embarrass other people I'd say that's
only the limiting factor I will do
anything to embarrass myself but when it
comes to affecting other people I really
don't want to embarrass them otherwise
I'm an open book if you come you got a
type of video that you want me to do lay
it on me makeup tutorials unboxing
videos I don't care
I'll do it all because that's that's the
thing I like about YouTube it's an open
book I get to do pretty much whatever I
want whenever I want and that is a super
freeing experience and because of that
I'm able to stay happy in making what I
want to make I always am happier when I
get to try new things and I think that
is the key to any project if you're
doing any sort of art art form YouTube's
not exactly an art form for me but you
know it's a fun expression of creativity
and I I think that's a beautiful thing
so in whatever you're doing out there
and whatever I'm doing just keep trying
new things always try to learn and
always try to push yourself beyond what
you could do before and then you'll
never stop moving so anyway that's all
the time I got for reading your comments
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been an enlightening experience
for both you and me but I know there are
more burning questions in your mind so
if you've got questions if you've got
requests if you've got challenges for me
to do write them down in the comments
below I would love to read them all and
try my hand at them so thank you again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye here